foreign
how do you teach someone to play your
game in an effective way how do you make
it engaging and comprehensible and is it
possible to organically weave a
controlled environment into the story
and setting without making it feel
forced or disconnected from the rest of
the game these are all questions devs
have been dealing with since the dawn of
gaming and the solutions differ from
genre to genre and changed as technology
progressed for the first Zelda game ever
made the solution was well you write a
freaking novel take all the information
a player needs to know including the
Overworld map controls enemy and item
catalogs and even the bulk of the story
and slap it into a booklet provided with
the cartridge it's about as old school
as it gets and not many games still do
it this way but honestly I think it
still has its charm as for the game
itself the player was given exactly one
screen to get to grips with the controls
before being confronted by enemies two
if you count the cave where link obtains
the first sword but there was nothing
restricting you from venturing into
Hyrule proper without it and the sword
cordless run has in fact been a
self-imposed challenge for seasoned
Zelda Veterans for a very long time as
if the game wasn't hard enough already
in A Link to the Past the freedom to
explore right from the get-go was
heavily toned down and players were
instead confined to Hyrule Castle which
served as the game's tutorial section
you had to fight and puzzle your way
through before being set free while the
castle does have a few branching paths
and optional areas it was still a
controlled and predominantly linear
experience quite the contrast from the
first title following A Link to the Past
a new standard for the game's starting
area would be set and repeated for most
Mainline Zelda titles in the years to
come instead of being airdropped into
the world and left your own devices or
navigating a linear Dungeness
environment the hero would often take
his first steps inside of a safe Zone
the circumstances do vary slightly from
game to game but the pattern is almost
identical you start out in a town often
times Link's Hometown you can't leave
until you've completed or triggered
certain story beats there's no enemies
to seek out and fight until the game
dictates as such you talk to NPCs who
explain some basic control or gameplay
elements give story Exposition or
provide menial tasks for link to do
until finally when you progress the
story enough a larger conflict or Quest
will be presented which will then send
link on his way and the true Adventure
Starts Now this was primarily a 3D Zelda
thing but there's no shortage of 2D or
top-down installments who adapted this
formula as well in fact Ocarina of Time
technically didn't even start this trend
but rather Link's Awakening did granted
you can get out of town and be on your
way in under a few minutes if you know
where to go so it wasn't nearly as
restrictive but still this linear and
formulaic approach to kicking off his
Zelda Adventure seemed to get taken to
the extreme with every new entry
Twilight Princess and Skyward Sword
especially are Infamous for their
long-winded confining story-driven
opening segments with lots of mandatory
tasks and dialogue to get through before
finally being sent on your way this
approach has garnered a lot of criticism
over the years particularly the argument
that opening segments like these can be
pretty jarring on repeat playthroughs
and to an extent I do agree with that
sentiment though my stance on it is a
bit more nuanced I don't actually hate
this way of starting out a Zelda game in
fact I can totally see why the
developers were coming from it can be an
effective way to do some World building
and create relationships and goals for
link and by extension the player to care
about and accomplish prior to kicking
off the main narrative the opening to
Twilight Princess and Skyward Sword may
be a bit of a drag to get through but
they also happen to be the games where I
care the most about the many Side
characters and by the end of the story
it's not just the heroes come a long way
but his friends as well from a father
who lost his children and joins a
resistance group in castletown an
insecure kid who finds the courage to
protect others a former bully who turns
into a hero himself to an insolent and
opportunistic sidekick who in time grows
to respect and care for the hero so no I
don't think this approach to opening up
a Zelda story was bad per se its
execution could have used some work and
an option to skip most of this fluff on
a second playthrough would have been
welcome but it did serve a purpose for
these particular stories that Twilight
Princess been the only game in the
series to start out this way I'm not too
sure if people would have complained
about it nearly as much the problem is
that almost every Mainline Zelda title
before and after was essentially
repeating the exact same Trope of a hero
from humble beginnings having his
peaceful life disrupted by some external
factor and then having a greater Destiny
thrown upon them again none of this is
bad on an individual level whether it's
saving your sister childhood friends or
love interests they're all effective
motivators to get link off his ass and
do what he does best burglary and
vandalism oh and saving the world of
course however when you do the same
thing enough time sooner or later it
does become formulaic and tiresome then
breath of the wild came along a game
Dead set on breaking conventions and in
some respects even taking a step back to
the roots of the series The developers
basically took a hatchet to many of the
series tropes and the quote-unquote
tutorial was no exception the great
Plateau is regarded as one of the best
opening segments to any Zelda game and
even games in general and for good
reason it ditches the metric tons of
force dialogue cutscenes and meaningless
chores in favor of a more open
free-flowing tutorial with a lot of
optional story and rewards and multiple
ways to overcome the same obstacle there
are still guidelines present here but
they aren't as obvious the so-called
Invisible Hand of Nintendo which is
mostly noticed only by those intent on
dissecting breath of the wild from a
game design perspective you know the
king case Mark Browns and Joseph
Andersons Among Us of course they
couldn't go all the way back to the NES
and just start the game with links
standing in the middle of a field
without any explanation or Exposition
whatsoever because as much as people may
think this was 100 done on purpose back
then the truth is that it was also just
part of the limitations of the medium
and because Zelda wasn't a massive story
driven lore-filled IP yet at this stage
I mean the entire story and goal can be
explained in just a few paragraphs so
there was essentially no need for
extensive dialogue and cutscenes however
with every entry the series did become
more story focused and lore heavy and
although breath the wild story is
fragmented and takes place more or less
in the background it still required some
kind of setup for Link's Quest and the
great Plateau serves that function
masterfully it teaches you most of what
you need to know about both the gameplay
and the main plot threads of what
happened to Hyrule during Link's absence
and the danger that still lurks deep
inside Hyrule castle and it does all of
this while wasting as little of your
time as possible making a second
playthrough a lot less cumbersome upon
exiting the shrine of resurrection and
stepping onto the great Plateau there's
only four mandatory dialogue exchanges
all of which are brief and a total of
three noteworthy cutscenes which are all
skippable even when viewing them for the
first time anything else is either
completely optional or shows up as a
prompt which barely interrupts the
gameplay which is in stark contrast to
previous titles Like the Wind Waker and
Twilight Princess where you were
essentially locked into obligatory
weapon tutorials the best aspect of the
great Plateau by far is just how vast
and non-restrictive it is sure you are
technically still in a controlled
environment barred from the rest of the
map but it's kinda hard to complain
about being confined to one area when
set area is roughly about the same size
as the entire world map of Ocarina of
Time as many have pointed out in the
past the cleverness of the plateau lies
in the fact that it's basically a
miniature version of larger Hyrule it
does still leave room for surprises but
it covers all the basics enemy camps
natural hazards the effects of extreme
temperature using the environment to
your advantage hunting Gathering and
cooking steep Cliffs teaching you about
stamina management it's all here the
plateau also mirrors the quest to free
the Divine beasts albeit on a smaller
scale after talking to impa you get the
option to seek out four points on the
map where the beasts are located in any
order you please on the plateau after
talking to the old man there are four
shrines which can be tackled in any
order too out of the four beasts farruta
is purposely positioned to be closest to
Link's current position and it's clear
that the Zelda team accounted for the
fact that most people will likely go
here first because the road to Zora's
domain features some of the weakest
enemy types likewise the closest of the
four shrines also happens to be the
easiest to get to with barely any
resistance while the road to the other
three are more treacherous and present
their own unique challenges still you
can completely ignore the intended path
which the devs accounted for as the old
man will always show up in whichever
Shrine you tackle first another more
subtle thing the plateau does is it
teaches you how Hyrule is meant to be
explored even if you don't realize it
for example moments before Zelda tells
link to head for the point marked on the
map the old man draws your attention to
the ruins of the Temple of Time he
doesn't say you have to go there he just
points it out to you like hey look at
these old ruins aren't they cool wink
wink so right away you have two points
of interest one with an objective marker
and one without it which only stands out
visually if you shoot straight for the
objective you'll encounter a bit more
hardship than you would have if you
checked out the temple first all the
enemies up to this point have been
singular one-on-one encounters wielding
sticks and clubs only but the road to
the sheikah tower will set you on a
collision course with the first enemy
groups as well as the first projectile
wielding and shield carrying enemies
which for an office player could be a
problem however if you visited and
properly explored the Temple of Time
first you would have been rewarded with
better armor a sword and one or two bows
and some arrows making the enemy
encounters on the path to the objective
significantly easier to deal with it
lets you know purely through World
design that it's okay and even
recommended not to blindly follow
objective markers and instead Venture
off the beaten path as you'll be
rewarded for your curiosity and that's
basically breath of the wild in a
nutshell right you aim for a specific
goal and on the way there you get
distracted by a million different things
and before you know it hours have passed
and you're not even close to that
initial goal you've set out to
accomplish so yeah suffice to say the
great Plateau is a master class in game
design and I will never get tired of
exploring it and analyzing all of its
intricacies it stands tall as my
favorite opening to any open world game
I've ever played so far and I've got
quite a few under my belt by this point
sure stepping out of Vault 101 while
your eyes try to adjust to the first
sunlight to ever hit your reticles was
amazing my first steps onto Lim grave in
Elden ring was also nothing short of
breathtaking but nothing comes close to
the pure ecstasy I felt during the first
hours exploring the great plateau in
breath of the wild it truly felt like
Nintendo finally got it it would have
been so easy for them to fall back into
old habits and bar off major sections of
the plateau in typical Zelda Flash like
I don't know you cannot access Mount
hylia because the cliffs are too high
and there's a boulder Block in the
entrance forcing you to get the remote
bombs first before you can access the
other two shrines but they didn't they
stayed committed to Breaking these types
of conventions and break them they sure
did so after all that gushing over the
great Plateau what about the upcoming
sequel how will it handle its tutorial
section leave it to a monster maze video
to get to the main topic 10 minutes in
right it feels kind of weird that I'm
actually excited about something like
the opening segment to a Zelda game
which prior to breath of the wild was
oftentimes the part I was just trying to
be done with so I could finally go on
the real Adventure it goes without
saying that the plateau still exists in
a new game since well it's the same
Hyrule but I think I'm not alone in
saying that I highly doubt we will start
the adventure here once again back in
the old days of the channel you know
when I still talk like an angry Dutch
guy this monster he just created will
serve as the first tutorial enemy for
link to test out his new green hand
ability I proposed that the cave system
Link and Zelda are seen traversing in
the first teaser could serve service the
tutorial section maybe after Zelda falls
into the abyss and Ganondorf has taken
off we'll have to escape the underground
and make our way back to the surface
somehow which would obviously be a more
linear approach to a tutorial akin to
the Vermin infested sewers over Link to
the Past now of course I made this
proposal long before we knew that the
sequel would feature a big emphasis on
Sky traversal and a lot more Revelations
have come out since then now it seems
increasingly unlikely that we'll take
our first steps deep underground
somewhere unless maybe it's for story
setup somewhere along the lines of the
opening to The Last of Us where you
don't actually play the game to its core
mechanics yet but are more so just
steering the character from cutscene to
cutscene for the sake of immersion but
that's not really a Zelda thing to do if
that makes any sense it also wouldn't be
much of a tutorial because we already
know from the footage and the patterns
issued by Nintendo that a big chunk of
Tears of the Kingdom's gameplay will be
centered around skydiving aerial combat
and Link's Afflicted arm and the new
abilities it brings with it the first
two of which are kinda hard to do on the
ground and as for the magical bracelet
it's apparent that he won't be in
possession of it and until after
Ganondorf attacks the hero which looks
to be taking place in a cutscene we also
know that this attack knocks him
unconscious as he's seen laying in the
dark on some kind of altar with the new
bracelet on his arm the symbols on this
altar also correspond to the ones we've
seen on some of the architecture in the
Sky Realm which were never seen on the
surface of Hyrule so maybe instead of
deep underground link comes too inside
of a building located on one of these
islands maybe this building I don't know
and the scene of Link pushing these
massive doors open will be this game's
equivalent of the moment link first ran
onto the cliff overlooking the great
Plateau I'm not saying it's impossible
that we may control link for the first
time in this underground setting maybe
we'll have some sort of pre-ordained
boss fight against Ganondorf one which
link is destined to lose which is a
classic way of instilling a sense of
fear and helplessness into the player
through gameplay instead of a cutscene
but again I wouldn't call this a
tutorial or opening area and more so an
interactive story setup if I had to
guess I'd say right now the most logical
option for a controlled environment
where the player will get the grips with
the game's core mechanics would be one
of the the islands in the sky one which
similar to The Great Plateau will have
ample amounts of explorable space but
link won't be able to leave the island
until he completes a number of Story
related tasks and has collected some
sort of key item just like the
paraglider in a previous title speaking
of the paraglider the one we see him use
in some of the teaser footage while
similar is not the same one from the
previous adventure and since link seems
to have been stripped of most of his
equipment including his clothes they
might just do a repeat here after all
without a paraglider jumping back down
to the surface would probably be
ill-advised so maybe escaping this
starting island is as simple as finding
the paraglider again which granted
wouldn't be very original but I mean if
it works it works right in the latest
teaser we can actually see a large
island or island group that looks big
enough to serve as an opening area it's
difficult to determine its exact size
given the perspective and lack of
reference but it looks like it could be
about the same size as the great Plateau
if not bigger the idea of Link being
stranded on a large island in the sky
after being injured by malice and then
having to look for a way down seems like
a pretty fitting introduction to me
after all the sky is the big new
addition to this iteration of Hyrule and
since we've spent so much time on the
surface in breath of the wild already it
just wouldn't make a lot of sense to me
to start the game down here again I know
not everyone who picks up tears of the
Kingdom will have played the original
but breath of the wild was a worldwide
phenomena and one of the best-selling
games of all time so I'd wager that the
majority of tiers of the king themselves
will be returning players who are
familiar with the original so with all
that said here's a quick summary of my
prediction for tears of the Kingdom's
opening we see the events from the first
teaser play out on the ground Link and
Zelda find ganon's corpse Zelda gets
yielded into the abyss while link
powerless to stop it gets his arm and
sword charred by malice knocking him
unconscious after this The Entity of
this bracelet originally belonged to
somehow takes link up into the sky to
heal his wounds and subsequently passes
the bracelet onto him to put a damper on
the infection spreading across his arm
which also makes him inherit some of the
powers and abilities this entity once
possessed when link comes to he will be
indoors and doesn't realize where he is
until he opens the front door to the
structure he's in as he steps out into
the daylight the Sky Realm is first
revealed and Link realizing he's stuck
up here goes on to explore this confined
area to look for something that can take
him down safely either in the form of
one or more powers for his new bracelet
or by obtaining something else like a
paraglider and pick up a few starting
weapons and gear on the way as well as
for why he would want to go back to the
surface as soon as possible we of course
don't know for sure but I can imagine
that he'd want to inform his friends on
the surface of what happened down in the
cave with Ganondorf and such after all
Link and Zelda were alone on this Quest
as far as we know and Zelda disappeared
and Link was knocked out so it's likely
that at this stage nobody except link
and Ganondorf know what happened to
Zelda while stuck up here link will also
fight his first grounded enemies either
on the island itself or inside one of
the many buildings scenes scattered
about which may act as many dungeons of
sorts that house the things he needs to
get back down to Hyrule like with the
great Plateau once he finds what he
needs link will finally be able to jump
down safely and leave the tutorial area
the fallback down to the surface is a
long and extensive one which may take a
couple of minutes and would be a perfect
opportunity to instruct the player on
the new skydiving mechanics like
controlling your direction and changing
poses they may even want to introduce
the first Airborne enemies on the way
down and teach you about aerial combat
like how to use the bow in free fall
which we know from the patterns will be
a new gameplay Edition as well finally
the hero will reach the surface back in
familiar territory and from here well
we'll just have to wait and see grocery
shopping perhaps but that's how I
currently think the first few hours or
so will more or less play out I could be
completely wrong about all of this but
hey that's why it's called a prediction
as for my final wishes regarding tears
of the Kingdom's opening and the game as
a whole for that matter I hope the game
will have a strong beginning but also
leave some room for growth amazement and
progression despite all the praise I've
given to the great plateau in this video
it did have one major flaw and that flaw
as ridiculous as it may sound is that it
was just too good so good in fact that
the first few hours of the game are the
ones I personally have the Fondest
Memories of now don't get me wrong I'm
not saying the rest of the game is bad
far from it but for some reason it did
feel like breath of the Wild's
experience kinda plateaued after the
great Plateau there's even some great
mechanics utilized on the plateau that
became pretty much redundant afterwards
in large part due to the paraglider the
game did have its fair share of high
points after the first few hours like
entering your first Divine Beast even
tight Island seeing a dragon for the
first time and storming the imposing
Hyrule Castle but I don't know it still
felt to me like with the great Plateau
the game may have peaked a little too
early for its own good I realize all too
well that this is a very subjective take
in your experience and opinions May
differ greatly but this is how I feel
about it when I think back to my first
playthrough of the game it's one aspect
I think Elden ring greatly improved upon
like I said before stepping into Lim
grave and seeing the gorgeous landscape
was awesome but I actually wasn't all
that Blown Away by Eldon ring in the
first few hours to be completely honest
I didn't hate it but I also didn't feel
the same sense of Amazement as I did did
back in 2017 however one major
difference is that Elden ring only
seemed to get better and better crazier
and crazier the moment you think you've
seen it all that you've reached the
absolute peak of the experience the game
throws something even more mind-blowing
your way it was kind of nuts and I hope
tears of the Kingdom can achieve
something similar a solid opening that
gets you excited but is also restrained
enough to leave some room for much much
greater things to come and that
concludes today's video thank you so
much as always for watching I feel like
I can never say it enough you guys
showing up time and time again really
makes my day the road to tears of the
Kingdom has been a long one but our
patience will finally pay off very soon
a special thanks to my mods Discord
community patreons and channel members
and I hope to see you in the next video
this is Dawn signing off and have a good
one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]